- Hey
- Hey! Jason, how are ya?
- Alright!
Thanks so much for coming over!
- Are you kidding? You remember
Trisha, my new girlfriend.
- Of course! Hey, we met last time.
- We did?
- Yeah.
- I don't remember.
- Oh.
- Nice, oh Randy Plymouth!
Huge comedy boner alert!
I've got a comedy boner right now!
- Get outta my house.
I'm not up for this.
- Hey I'm a huge fan.
I love it when you play pull my finger.
- You don't know me.
You don't know me.
- Okay, this is a side of Randy Plymouth
that I haven't seen and I like.
You guys wanna party?
I brought a six pack and
some pretty good white stuff.
- Yeah I'll show you the coke room.
- Hey Randy, no.
- I wanna show it.
I'll show you the coke room.
- There's no coke room tonight.
Hey Tidal, I told you, Randy
is clean, he's a month sober,
he's doing great.
- Okay, hey so he really is sober.
Jason, you wanna-
- No I'm good, I'm great.
It's the middle of the day.
- Okay well now I feel like a jerk.
- Oh no, no I'm sorry
don't feel like a jerk,
I mean, have fun, that's cool.
- Oh no I just feel like a
jerk 'cause I brought so much.
I'm still gonna.
[Hardcore Electronic Music]
- Hey know what, this is
probably not the best thing
for Randy to be watching.
Randy, what are you doing?
- [Tidal] Alright now he's ready to party.
- [Jason] Randy, Randy
- Get the fuck away from me.
I'm not gonna sit here and watch-
- Put it down Randy!
Put it down!
You know what, I feel really bad.
We shouldn't be doing
this in front of him.
- Alright let's finish off these lines
and then we'll do a couple more
and then we'll be good to go.
Slide! (laughs) Yeah!
- We have to leave okay?
The nanny's bringin' the kids over.
- Okay good.
- Randy Plymouth, it's been an honour.
I can't wait to make
comedy genius with ya.
- Alright
- Wait a minute.
So, we sold it?
- Yeah of course you sold it!
Hell yeah you did!
I love the mansion, I love the concept,
I love Randy Plymouth.
Live from Randy Plymouth's
playhouse, it's gonna be good!
- [Randy] Really?
- [Jason] That's great news.
- Do you guys have any rubbers?
[Upbeat Rock Music]